What’s the point of putting lipstick on
a guinea pig?
Other than making the guinea pig look fabulous,
obviously.
Hello there lovely people, Amy here on DNews.
I wear cosmetic products, obviously, and probably
do, too, even if you don’t think you do.
That’s because along with makeup, moisturizers,
and nail polish, the US Food and Drug Administration’s
(FDA) definition of cosmetics includes things
like shampoo, deodorant, and toothpaste.
Unless those cosmetics also treat something
like dandruff or cavities, provide sun protection,
or have a color additive, the FDA has no authority
to regulate them and it’s up to the cosmetic
company to make sure they’re safe before
they hit the market.
There are a lot of factors to consider when
testing a cosmetic.
Manufacturers need to know if products will
cause an allergic reaction; if they’ll cause
temporary or irreversible skin or eye damage;
at what point they’re toxic if absorbed
through the skin, lungs, or digestive tract;
the effects of long-term exposure; if they’re
carcinogenic; if they cause infertility; or
if they cause birth defects.
Pretty much all the things you need to worry
about if you’re a teenage boy who overuses
body spray.
But cosmetic companies can’t jump straight
to testing on teenage boys because they’d
probably get a call from their irate mothers.
No.
Companies don’t test on people because it’s
inhumane and if something goes wrong, it might
irreparably harm a human being.
Before a human uses a product, we have to
be sure they’re reasonably safe, so for
a long time animals were used to test the
chemicals in cosmetics first.
Usually the tests involve mice, rats, guinea
pigs or bunnies.
Understandably, many people consider these
tests inhumane, and some places like Europe
have banned products that have been tested
on animals entirely.
Other places like China actually require animal
testing on the finished products.
The FDA’s stance falls somewhere in the
middle: companies are neither encouraged or
discouraged to test on animals, though the
FDA has stated they would like to gain the
maximum amount of information using the fewest
animals as humanely as possible.
Depending on what they’re testing for, scientists
might use just one bunny or as many as 2600
mice.
Cosmetic makers would probably rather not
test on animals if they could avoid it.
It’s expensive and a PR nightmare.
Plus using an animal for testing a chemical’s
effects on people can be imprecise because,
well, they’re not people.
But scientists are developing methods that
substitute animals for test tubes.
The Johns Hopkins Center for Alternatives
to Animal Testing, appropriately acronymed
to CAAT, is foremost in in vitro testing.
But some things, like how a product behaves
when inhaled, still can’t be replicated
artificially.
Other proposed methods involve using mathematical
models to extrapolate how thousands of different
chemicals will behave after testing just a
tiny fraction.
Either way, learning more about what we put
on and in our bodies is always a valuable
pursuit, otherwise we could end up like the
Romans, who unknowingly poisoned themselves
with white lead used for makeup foundation.
All for the sake of beauty.
Ultimately, moving away from animal testing
will require some innovative changes, as do
most
Tech innovations are constantly changing our
lives – both professionally and personally.
If you are fascinated with the latest in tech
innovations and how they are impacting the
world around you, check out Full Sail University.
Full Sail has spent 30 years developing degree
programs that help you build a skill set for
the tech industry.
To learn more about these programs, and all
of Full Sail’s technology degree programs,
visit fullsail.edu/DNews
A lot of research depends on using animals,
particularly lab mice.
But why mice?
Trace explains here.
Though cosmetic testing on animals gets more
attention, most animal testing is done for
pharmaceutical or biomedical research.
Is using animals ok for one and not the other?
Share your thoughts in the comments and remember
to subscribe so you never miss an episode
of DNews.
Thanks for watching.